Voiceover:Cosine of two theta is equal to C
and theta is between zero and pi.
Write a formula for sine
of theta in terms of C
and so I encourage you to pause the video
and try to figure this out on your own
before I work through it.
So assuming you had a go,
so let's see if we can
work through it together.
I'm going to get my scratchpad out,
I have copied and pasted
the exact question
right over here, and so
let's think about it.
They're telling us that
cosine of two theta
is equal to C, so let
me write it this way.
C is equal to cosine of two theta.
Now, using my knowledge of
angle addition formulas,
we know for example that cosine of
alpha plus beta is equal to cosine alpha
cosine beta minus sine alpha sine beta.
Now why would this be useful here?
Well this is the sum of
just theta plus theta,
and so I can rewrite this in terms of
cosines and sines and maybe I can rewrite
the cosines in terms of sines
and then solve for the sines.
So let's try to do that.
So I can rewrite cosine of
two theta that's the same
as cosine of theta plus
theta, is of course the same
thing as two theta, and I can use the
angle addition formula for cosine.
This is going to be
equal to cosine of theta,
times cosine of theta,
minus sine of theta, times sine of theta,
time sine of theta, which is of course
equal to cosine squared
theta, that's equal to
cosine squared theta,
minus and what we have
right over here is sine squared theta.
So let's see, we've been able to rewrite C
in terms of cosine squared theta and
sine squared theta, but ideally we just
want to write it in terms of sine theta
so we can solve for sine theta.
So if we can re-express
cosine theta in terms of sine.
Well we already know from
the pythagorean identity
that cosine squared theta plus sine
squared theta is equal
to one, or we could say
that cosine squared theta is equal to,
I'm just going to subtract
sine squared from both
sides, is equal to one
minus sine squared theta.
So let me rewrite this
as one minus sine squared
theta, and then of course we have minus
this yellow sine squared theta,
and all of this is equal
to C or we could get that C
is equal to one minus
two sine squared theta.
And what's useful about this is we just
have to solve for sine of theta.
So let's see, I could
multiply both sides by a
negative just so I can
switch the order over here.
So I could write this as negative C
is equal to two sine squared theta
minus one and just multiply both sides
by a negative and then
let's see I could add
one to both sides, if I
add one to both sides,
and I'll go over here, if
I add one to both sides,
I get one minus C is equal
to two sine squared theta,
I could divide both sides by two,
and then so I get sine squared theta
is equal to one minus C over two,
or I could write that sine of theta
is equal to the plus or minus square root
of one minus C over two.
So that leads to a question,
Is it both?
Is it the plus and minus square root?
Or is it just one of those?
And I encourage you to
pause the video again
in case you haven't
already figured it out,
and look at the information here,
and think about whether
they give us the information
of whether we should be looking
at the positive or negative sine.
Well they tell us that theta
is between zero and pi.
So if I were to draw a unit circle here,
between zero and pi radians.
So, this angle right over
here is zero radians,
and pi is going all the way over here.
So this angle places its terminal ray
either in the first or second quadrants.
So, it could be an angle like this,
it could be an angle like this,
it cannot be an angle like this,
and we know that the sine of an angle
is the Y coordinate, and so we know that
for the first of second
quadrant the Y coordinate
is going to be non-negative.
So we would want to take
the positive square root,
so we would get sine of theta,
is equal to the principal root,
or we could even think of it
as the positive square root
of one minus C over two.
So let's go back to our...
Make sure we can check our answers.
So sine of theta is
equal to the square root
of one minus capital C,
all of that over two,
and we got it right.